so there is a lot of like the the style
in here like the way you were singing
Rachel first of all is so beautiful Your
V
is but I love how you go it's almost
like singer songwriter Little Country
folk in there like was this all planned
that vibe that sound yeah I mean you
could probably attest to this better
than I can but uh Suzanne used to be a
country music DJ yes and so it was one
of those things that she's that she's
been so immersed in that world and the
the you know District 12 geographically
is North Carolina Appalachian very
Southern so that music was very like Jug
Band folksy country music and she had an
a clear idea of what she wanted all of
the songs she had actually written out
the lyrics in the book what she wanted
them to sound like she sent me she told
me I should look the at the Ken Burns
country document oh God it's so good and
it's amazing and it was in the pandemic
so I had a lot of time on my hand so I
watched all I think 16 hours but what I
fell in love with was that era from the
20s and the 30s with the Carter family
and with magel Carter and all of that
and Wildwood Flower and those songs and
I think that's kind of the era that she
was really pulling from when thinking of
these ballads and these songs that
passed down through generations M and
and one of the reasons uh Rachel plays
the big guitar to the big Gibson is we
were basing that off of mayel Carter's
guitar that she played oh I love that
everything had purpose oh that's Beau
exactly yeah and then she just fit right
in and like got the tone of it all so
perfectly and then what what I will say
that was amazing is that she sang Live
every day I look that's my next
thing that is my next thing I heard that
you did sing live and you're a singer
but I just people don't get you have to
do those takes over and over and over
again like it's a lot to do that live
like and so that's incredible not
everybody I don't many people do that
I've never ever seen somebody do every
take
incredible
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home